hey Carmichael so tomorrow is
Thanksgiving oh Jesus oh god that's
scary oh yeah actually well I am quite
thankful for this blog actually at the
making a video every other day for a
full year can stress you out can push
you and can really teach you how to get
something done and how to work harder
and faster to achieve the same goal well
I'm thankful for all you viewers because
you allow us to live this ridiculous
lifestyle where I get paid to create art
and ride around on electric vehicles
like this and just do dumb stuff with my
friends and I have an outlet where you
know people can watch it it's like what
more can I ask for I'm not thankful for
Nico Nico can leave a comment saying
what you guys are thankful for because
I'm actually legitimate curious because
we actually read mostly comments and so
if you guys are thankful for anything
let us know cuz I might be reading them
I got nothing to do from the next four
days so tak away I have things to do I
have friends twig on
here in the dollar
look at my knee